foreign
could you Define dissociation and then
share your perspective on whether it is
helpful
AKA desirable or undesirable
in the in the effects that we see the
antidepressant effects
you know sometimes I have started papers
on dissociation and stopped because I
would get hung up on what the definition
of dissociation is
our consciousness
our experience of the world
our sense of ourself in the world
our sense of our bodies
our sense of ourselves embedded in time
all of these things which
people take for granted
are constructions of our brain active
constructions and when these fundamental
aspects of the organization of
consciousness
are perturbed
we experience ourselves
as disconnected
from ourselves
in other words depersonalized
or in an artificial state
which is also called derealization in
other words that you're in an altered
reality
and those
states of derealization and
depersonalization as well as distortions
in our
perception of ourselves
and the perception of the world as
integrated
are collectively what we tend to refer
to as dissociative States because
dissociation meaning disconnected from
what's going on around us but really
it's a much more profound and nuanced
idea because you can have some
Distortion of dissociation in some
dimensions and not others and it can be
very nuanced I got interested in
dissociation
because of working with Vietnam veterans
with post-traumatic stress disorder and
for whom dissociation is a
complication or a part of the syndrome
of post-traumatic stress disorder for
many people
and it's a whole nuanced range of things
from these states of feeling
disconnected and and that things are not
real
too sensory distortions
to
what people know as a very
dramatic aspect of PTSD which are these
flashbacks where people are completely
absorbed in another state and lose touch
with what's happening around them and so
one of the things that was exciting
about the initial ketamine research
was that it was not only providing us a
way a new way to think about the
neurobiology of psychosis and cognitive
impairments associated with
schizophrenia but it was also at the
same time providing us with really the
first
pure
kind of neurobiological path to studying
the neurobiology dissociation in PTSD
and that's a whole other kind of
discussion which we can we can come back
to so
what about dissociation in the
antidepressant effects Academy this is
really an interesting and complicated
question because to really answer your
question you have to acknowledge I have
to acknowledge that I'm a translational
neuroscientist and psychiatrist I do
work on trying to understand the most
basic aspects of
biochemistry synaptic signaling Network
function computational modeling whatever
and so
there are aspects of engaging in
treatment that are not
so close to that like what did it mean
to me to go through this experience and
and so a lot of people say that the
dissociative experience is a very
meaningful experience for them
particularly if there's some kind of
guided experience to do that and I have
no argument with that whatsoever why not
in fact that's great
but
I've seen a lot of people who get
ketamine for treatment
and a lot of people who just get
ketamine I've given well over a thousand
doses Academy to people
from it's not really that much of a
meaningful experience I've had people
say things like
well
my parents scrimped and saved to send me
to medical school and now I'm losing
control of my thought processes during
ketamine I'm throwing away my parents
investment you know that you know these
kinds of scary thoughts my
my organs are being replaced with
machine parts
that sounds unpleasant yeah you know
stuff like that and that is not a
productive insight and it's not healing
it's not important for them to even
remember that after the ketamine is worn
off
so I would say the dissociation is
clearly not a necessity
in terms of producing attitude change
and things like that
I would also say that some people they
get the ketamine and
I once had a treated a guy or it wasn't
it was a research study but I gave him a
dose Academy he had come from a Mormon
background he had never had coffee and
never had tea never had alcohol never
smoked never used any drug and and he
described ketamine as the most fun he
ever had since he arrived at Yale so it
was like a roller coaster of like doing
all these things I mean it clearly has
that heart to it as well
so the question is is dissociation
telling us something important and I
think there are ways that it does on my
side of the street which is that as I've
mentioned
it just so happens
that the dose of ketamine that is
optimal
for inducing the antidepressant effects
is for many people the dose at which
they experience dissociative symptoms
the dose that produces the therapeutic
effects the Dosa produce dissociation
overlap so that if you're giving a dose
of ketamine that is is not producing any
dissociative symptoms for some people it
will mean you have underdosed the
academy
when there are exceptions to this in
that some people are just not very
sensitive to the dissociative effects of
ketamine but still get the
antidepressant effects and examples of
those people are people who have a
personal or family history of alcohol
use disorder who seem to have a built-in
tolerance to the effects of ketamine as
they do have a built-in tolerance some
of them to the effects of
alcohol and that's another story we can
get to if you want sometime but what my
colleagues
Arena estilus and Sophie Holmes and and
the broader
group of collaborators with Yale pet
center did a study which I think is
incredibly important and interesting
related to the neurobiology academy
which sheds light a little bit on
dissociation and that is
they had previously reported that a
subgroup of patients with relatively
more severe depression had reductions in
synaptic density and they could show
that with pet scans with using a
molecular tag for synapses
and so okay so there's these depressed
patients who have reductions in synaptic
density
great so that so far that could be
relevant to translating the animal work
to the human work
so you give a mixed group of depression
patients some who have synaptic deficits
others who don't have synaptic deficits
and you give them a dose of ketamine
what happens this paper was from this
same group published this year
turns out that the people who have
synaptic deficits which are the more
treatment resistant the more severely
ill more chronically ill
et cetera et cetera the more hardcore
depressed patients
they get a dose Academy
they get us an increase in synaptic
density
and the more dissociative symptoms they
get
the bigger the increase in synaptic
density and the bigger the increase in
synaptic density
the greater their clinical Improvement
pilot data really preliminary but very
interesting so it suggests that in
people who have synaptic deficits that
dissociative symptoms produced by
ketamine can be a marker
that you've got enough ketamine into the
brain and you're triggering the
therapeutic antidepressant effects but
what about those
other depressed patients the other half
of the patients with depression who are
getting ketamine
they don't have synaptic deficits
what happens to them they get
dissociation too
but
dissociation in those patients is
unrelated to their clinical response and
if anything it's not really so
meaningful but there's a little bit of a
trend that the more dissociation they
get the less Improvement they get not
meaningful but maybe it's there a little
bit so
so dissociation in these two groups of
patients during ketamine means two
different things yeah in one it's a
signature of clinical Improvement and
another it's not
and what that highlights is really
number one ketamine is doing different
things because the people who don't have
synaptic deficits are still getting
clinical Improvement overall
but they're not getting clinical
Improvement that's related to the
restoration of structural connectivity
they don't have that kind of depression
they don't have the deficits in synaptic
density and it's not regrowing so what
could it be